hello welcome to this video I am hyper
jaw with the opponent let's see Enrique
see Enrique are pass yenza ok ok I was
winning earlier with this against them
mr. sauerkraut wow that's that's very
risky actually let's see um should be
five Bishop c6 Queen a form
should be five push-ups e6 Queen a form
i would see Kelsey I'll see you Jesse
doing that that seemed even taking us
pretty strong take screen a form now
that that that shouldn't be right
actually
so let's not screw this up 95
95 96 III context can you survive that
Bishop takes Queen TX 97 the ship a
three Wow can you survive that can also
take here now nine ticks and it's going
to look c8 again I'm just spending too
much time trying to refute that I mean
what I don't give me that crap this is
working why if I go a three here and
queen d forward no that's not working
I don't think he can play this thing I
don't believe it ose six just about
holding him Bishop f4 threatening 93
can't believe it I cannot believe
f 693 e5 is that playable where I'm
probably not in half night xe5 so 93
check with winning the champion right
colac resigns gasps oh here Jack I have
this one so let's check this I mean I
was pretty stunned by this opening its
ad lets out a risky yeah what he did
here because of the the diagonal I came
the computer actually wants to do 95 and
Tess I'm waiting maybe that is ballet if
the computer gives winning it's probably
a sure sign of course it's related him
the engine gives this as the best line
in her black [ __ ] this of course much
better maybe that was better and just
looked very strong also here Queen here
95 and then he played this well this is
this is insane move I mean I was
actually not totally sure how to how to
win here Bishop e3 of course I saw that
but I wasn't sure how to win okay a form
and F what seems to win if you believe
stockfish and you probably should know a
six and then queen back just playing
this position it just plus one it's not
I mean winning is a strong word it's
it's just plus one but how amazing that
black and survive this but here Bishop
f4 would have won okay what I did maybe
also i don't know a 3 is plus five
Bishop f4 is even stronger than now I
came I had seen this idea and now taking
I was thinking that this should be good
okay what does the comp give just plus
one so it seems to be still not a lot of
complete way know anything f6 is the
move and then this it's the best defense
for black amazing and no there's yeah
good luck and playing that one yeah okay
white white is better but it's some it's
not clear it's a mess it's a ringer
that's okay and this is probably
probably winning right yeah be sure
therefore you cannot defend anymore
check checked him he loses the Queen
back Wow ok how was funny thanks for
watching